the Transformer that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now no nothing's in the get Trump era
they're not reporters they're repeaters
because there's not an original thinker
in the media Bunch they can't get past
the last New York Times headline they
read
Donald Trump impeached in and of itself
historic now he's the only president to
be impeached twice president Trump's
historic second impeachment trial set to
kick off a historic situation it's the
first time a former president has ever
been indicted on federal charges the
scope and scale is historic it is quite
unparalleled
oh unparalleled too these people are so
bent in the head over Trump that they've
become what they claim he is unhinged
and unable to see the damage they're
doing to Norms and Democratic Values now
and they're Relentless pursuit of
Biden's Chief antagonist A.G Merrick
Garland and his prosecutorial Hitman
Jack Smith are doing more damage to
America than any group of capital
rioters ever could
but this anti-trump contagion has spread
far beyond the doj in the media it's
even infected that a gus group of
American historians who are supposed to
be able to distill the full sweep of
national and world events without a
blinding political bias
behold Michael beschlas the Elite's
go-to Basher of conservatives
masquerading as a learned historian
Donald Trump is who our Founders dreaded
9 11 2001 Osama Bin Laden and other
terrorists hated our democracy try to
destroy it Donald Trump just like those
other threats to American democracy
tried to destroy our system to take away
our rule of law
and when he's not busy on Martha's
Vineyard well there's always Doris
Kearns Goodwin best known for
plagiarizing from multiple other authors
well listen to this and tell me how you
distinguish her and her comments from
those of a Biden campaign organizer just
frustrated by Trump's continuing appeal
we got to figure out when is that going
to happen when is it going to break it's
going to take the overwhelming
organization organizing the country at
all the levels so that he cannot win
that election if the party will will not
depart from him then he has to be
defeated and the depart the party has to
be defeated
huh it must be my misunderstanding I
guess because I always thought that
historians were individuals who wrote
about different arcs of the political
parties and events their leaders
not people who call for political action
in the future
of course the only thing worse than
today's actual historians are those who
pretend to know history
we had the American Revolution that
started the country we had the Civil War
now you're on the side of America and
what it conceptually stands for or are
you on the side of King George or the or
the Confederates that's where I would
cast Donald Trump and let him defend
that are you for democracy or are you
for autocracy
poor Reverend Al like so many putting
heads on TV he doesn't know what the
term autocracy even means
because true autocrats do things like
enrich their families sensor speech put
their political opponents on trial and
of course collude with corporations
against innocent citizens
but beyond these pundit historians there
actually is good news out there every
once in a while even among Die Hard
never trumpers comes an Insight worth
sharing
such was the case in a piece just
published in the Financial Times by
Gideon Rockman with the actual eye to
what matters long-term Rockman argues
that love him or hate him Trump will go
down in American history as a
transformational figure because of his
policies policies that marked a sharp
break from the Clinton Bush Obama era in
issues like trade globalization and
China
writing that Trump repudiated the
pro-globalization consensus of the
previous 40 years on his first day in
office Trump pulled America out of the
TPP in 2017 the U.S made a deliberate
effort to hobble the WTO Robert
lighthizer Trump's trade rep imposed a
raft of tariffs on China
now many of those tariffs remain in
place two and a half years after Biden's
inauguration Lord knows how much lower
our GDP would be if he had removed them
Rockman continued saying this
Trump's victory in 2016 forced Democrats
to take the plight and anger of U.S
workers much more seriously and
important respects therefore Trump
brought about a lasting revolution in
U.S foreign and domestic policy
again
that's what's called honest analysis
from someone who intensely disagrees
with Donald Trump
and look voters are not stupid they know
how much better things were five years
ago check out this new survey by ipsos
73 percent of those surveyed said the
economy is worse off now than it was in
2018 under Trump
meanwhile Biden's job approval is stuck
at 38 percent with a staggering 60
percent of independents disapproving
[Music]
well sure is danger danger for Biden in
2024 or it should be if Republicans keep
the focus on the economy
and let's not forget another issue where
Trump was transformative the Border by
every measure Americans are outraged at
the human the economic and the crime
problems Biden's open border zealots
have created
nearly three quarters are saying that
they're doing a bad job at the border
but before Trump let's remember the GOP
was generally pretty unreliable on
illegal immigration pushing things like
amnesty they call it comprehensive
immigration reform instead of
comprehensive enforcement
the transformation that Trump ushered in
left the bushes and the cheneys and the
Dust
and this dramatic shift toward populism
was on display for everyone to see and
everyone to hear at a recent McConnell
event in Kentucky
[Applause]
[Music]
I love how they kept clapping
and the message even comes through when
Old Guard globalists speak at Trump
rallies ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome United States Senator Lindsey
Graham
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all for coming
thank you very very much
thank you thank you for booing me
well the establishment in both parties
they're grudgingly finding out that you
can only defy your voters for so long
following the demands of big donors or
Fringe activists means today you're
pretty conventional you're not
transformational when you do that but
Define the status quo to stand with the
people even under the threat of
imprisonment
that means you're not just
transformational you're historic and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else